- Your son has a famous godfather.
And I found this amazing, I
didn't know this connection.
So who, who's your guy?
Can you tell everybody, who the godfather?
- Oh, I can tell everybody.
Yeah, he's somebody that
I admire and respect,
not only as an amazing
father, an amazing husband,
amazing musician, and an amazing actor.
His name's Tim McGraw.
- [Kelly] That's so crazy cool.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It was look, we,
I've known him for a long time.
We laugh about it because it's been
probably over 17 years now
that we did "Friday
Night Lights" together,
we played father and son.
So I got to first experience him,
you know, as a father in that film,
a little more of somewhat an abusive one.
But then we did "Country Strong" together.
And we've remained such
close friends, and the
you know, I've seen his
children and his daughters
from the time they were
one, three and five, now.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You know.
- It's kinda cool for him
because he doesn't have a boy.
So to get to play a father.
- Of course, and that's the
yeah, and so, you know?
- He's got a lot of estrogen
rocking that household.
- He does, he feels sometimes singled out.
- Yeah, I would to.
- But,
no, he's the best.
And, when I said that,
you know, after around the 12 weeks,
you know, kind of time
of Emma being pregnant.
- Yeah.
- I called him.
And the first thing he said
was, "I'm the godfather."
So.
- [Kelly] That's so cool.
- How can you argue?
- Yeah, it's a beautiful thing
to ask of someone too, so.